hallo mein name ist nun kommt meine
lieben zuschauer wir schauen uns heute
gemeinsam ein video an mit einem titel
der dümmer wohl gar nicht sein kann
increase york university ist ronny
survivals and crime passion ende des
heutigen videos ist unser intelligenz
konzern angeblich 20 prozent höher als
er davor war ja ich würde sagen wir
verlieren gar keine zeit und zwar kommen
wir schon zum ersten rätsel wir sind an
einem bus stop und ein bus fährt mit
höchstgeschwindigkeit an uns vorbei der
fahrer des busses realisiert dann dass
seine bremsen kaputt sind und er den bus
nicht stoppen kann einiger dass wir
haben absolute albtraum der bus wird
immer schneller und schneller also die
geschwindigkeit geht immer mehr nach
oben und die passagiere fangen an panik
zu kriegen und fangen an rom zu schreien
doch plötzlich fährt der bus eine zweite
break windows but fail also die
passagiere wollen die scheiben kaputt
machen aber kriegen es irgendwie nicht
hin
watch it you tube 77 sekunden zeit
ich würde sagen er lenkt den bus einfach
nach links oder nicht
besser
[Musik]
also ich meine es ja logisch wenn ein
berg hochfährt
die geschwindigkeit wird ja nur weniger
die ach du heilige scheiße bin ich dumme
stück hotel stehen dir noch immer an den
wahnsinn lukather wer den vogel
abgeschossen und bahn allerdings trägt
weiter mit dem nächsten rätsel your
stuck in the desert hot water also wir
sind in der wüste und haben kein wasser
wir wandern schon seit einigen stunden
durch die wüste hierdurch und werden
wahrscheinlich verdursten when you come
across also wir kommen jetzt tatsächlich
zu einem see und das sind wir
but the latest hast du okay wir haben
einen see gefunden mitten in der wüste
keine ahnung wo sonst sehen mitten in
der wüste auf einmal auftauchen soll
allerdings besteht der see aus
salzwasser added reseller und hat also
alle bäume die um den see herum stehen
oder der indem sie drin
diesen alle told you have the bottle
plate in some matches okay also wir
haben feuerzeuge
wir haben eine flasche und einen bart
sein
[Musik]
also ich würde irgendwie sagen wasser in
die schüssel und dann anzünden und dann
in die model und dann kann man das
vielleicht trinken und dann ist ja kein
salz werden
wo hat er dieses blatt her wenn
angeblich alle bäume um den see rom tot
sein sollen
und er fragte doch gerade seine haare ab
aber okay wir machen weiter und am ende
haben wir uns 20 prozent höheren
intelligenzquotienten lost found dead in
his house also billig wurde tot in
seinem haus gefunden
delays ohne paddel of water also er
liegt in einem kleinen wasser sehe hier
drin mit einer wunde in seiner brust
also ich muss mir irgendwas in die brust
gefallen bitte ja wahrscheinlich etwas
in die brust gefallen hat nowak in
moskau und in der haus also die haben
keine waffe gefunden
they were only three people in der haus-
und ähnliches rätsel hatten wir schon
mal einen gärtner ein mensch und ein
koch what have you been doing this
morning fragt der polizist und der
gärtner antwortete bosworth going to
have a little night also der typ der
ermordet wurde
feiert heute abend angeblich eine party
und der hat dann rosen aus dem garten
geschnitten um damit diese haus zu
dekorieren
der typ hat das haus gesorgt weil er ja
debusmann frau ist und der typ hat
wunderschöne eis formen geschaffen für
die partygäste der police believe that
one of them ist dick heller okay ich
würde mal sagen der koch weil der typ
liegt in der wasserlache und er hat ihn
wahrscheinlich mit irgend einem spitzen
gegenstand getötet also mal abwarten was
sie als lösung bei rumkommt es wäre das
erste rätsel dass ich tatsächlich hier
richtig lösen könnte und es ist der koch
e mail live and kill bill ja also gehört
wie ich aussehe bin ich dann doch nicht
will daher also wer wird sterben dass
ihr die nächste frage ist es direkt auf
zeit es wird nicht mehr
erläutert werden die hälfte der zeit
einmal sind drei leute auf seinem stuhl
ich würd sagen ich habe keine ahnung wie
ich setze mich derzeit nicht mehr weil
sie nicht okay dass es nicht verbunden
mit dem strom auch soll es scheiße
sondern eher von sieben sekunden achten
wie ich sonst hätte ich ihn gehirn aber
auch hier ist wieder die frage hugel da
er so wäre jetzt sterben
sie ist ganz vorne sie ist festgekettet
mit dem ding also ja sie wird sterben
er ist ja nicht mit dem er wird sterben
safe oder 7
hauptsache ich sage entweder die oder
der und der als tatsächlich dann die
lösung habe ich jetzt mal real talk ich
mein kummer sie ist mit ihrer kette hier
darum also sie wird sich wahrscheinlich
selbst erhängen und er ich meine füße
sind auf der neuen seite der wäsche
längst rausgeflogen
das hier ist das nächste wer wird
sterben rätsel
das sind drei feuerwehrleute der hier
löschte der löscht mit seinem mantel und
er liegt zwischen zwei teilen am er
brennt aber schon also selbst der hier
oder
wolter auf der einen seite denke ich mir
das könnte sein dass es im video liegt
und die erläuterung einfach ein bisschen
komisch und auf der anderen seite habe
ich halt angst dass ich einfach wirklich
ziemlich dumm bin
das kommt natürlich auch sagen wir auch
wieder die frage wer sterben wird
der eine läuft auf eine schlange zu der
anderen auf ein loch zu der andere wird
von einem wolf verfolgt er hatte ja
keine ahnung ich würde sagen der weil er
nicht weil er kann das hier ist das
nächste rätsel und zwei judoka
bindemittel auf den desert also wir sind
einfach in einer wüste auf warte ich
mein werk endlich war auch jeden zweiten
tag in der wüste auf glücklicherweise
hast du eine magische lampe neben dir ja
das ist ja wahnsinn also es bei mir
wirklich auch immer so europe did they
came out okay also da kommt jetzt ein
geist raus ok ein genie der einem ein
wunsch erfüllt ein old and can't get any
which ist also wir uns doch keinen
wunsch erfüllen but you can't you as one
of the magic artifex also wir können uns
eines von mehreren verschiedenen sachen
aussuchen die er mit dabei hat the magic
packet kennen overview food and drinks
okay also die tasche gibt uns unzählig
wasser und essen was er für mich glaube
ich das absolute wahnsinn style wäre
dann haben wir noch das 7 leaks boots
ich habe keine ahnung was das sein soll
und der ebro denn wie let you planet
trade
csafe diese brille oder das hier ist das
nächste rätsel ist rhodos on the beach
mit haircuts also mit rogers mit ihren
drei kindern namen shawn michaels und
ellison am strand und dann wollen die
alle los und eis essen gehen ich meinen
klar wenn man am strand ist will man
natürlich auch ein reis essen ellison
soll auf jeden fall auf ihre jüngeren
geschwister aufpassen
when she came back michael j ja das
passiert mir auch immer wenn ich am
strand bin nikes angeblich im wasser
ertrunken also im meer hat er eigentlich
keine luft mehr bekommen the police
interview the children also die polizei
fragt die kinder am my boyfriend called
me sagt die auch solltest auf deinen
bruder aufpassen digger also sie sagt
auf jeden fall dass ihr freund sie
angerufen hat und sie deswegen mikey aus
den augen verloren hat und der andere
sagt wiebe player also er hat einen ball
und ist damit mit mir in der pushed into
the wild also ich habe keine ahnung wer
für den tod verantwortlich sein soll die
eine person war angeblich am
telefonieren die andere person war
ja da gar kein handy mit also ich würde
sagen dass die tochter verantwortet
jetzt schien
das kann doch nicht wahr sein alter
weise die antworten alles so bescheuert
com leute wie man jetzt das letzte
rätsel pool drei first also wer wird als
erstes sterben wir haben eine person
hier in der wüste die kein wasser mehr
hat wüste kam ja heute schon mal vorn
auf der anderen seite haben wir eine
person die auf dem wasser ist aber auf
einer luftmatratze
wer wird als erstes sterben ist die
frage von daher habe ich absolut mich
absolut keine ahnung jäger wenn ich
nicht jetzt entscheiden müsste würde ich
glaube ich die person auf der linken
seite nehmen weil die person auf der
rechten seite ich habe absolut keine
ahnung ich weiß es nicht
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden wenn der liebe
zuschauer hm ich habe ja schon viermal
tatsächlich ein video auf einem kanal
hochgeladen mit dem titel wer steht
zuerst das kann man mal mega gut bei
euch an und alle leute wann immer in den
kommentaren am alten sohn die person die
die person und jetzt bin ich sogar auf
euch angewiesen weil ihr quasi ja also
wir haben ja keine lösung bekommen für
den fall jetzt gerade wer wird eurer
meinung nach als erste sterben entweder
eine person die in der wüste ist und
kein wasser mehr hat oder eine person
auf einer luftmatratze mitten auf dem
meer schweiz der gerne und in die
kommentare das einen daumen hoch bei dem
video da wenn es euch gefallen hat und
abonniert main kanal falls noch keine
freiheit
[Musik]